nous voulions rendre ce Pirates des
Caraïbes vraiment spécial et vraiment
frais, nous avons donc eu deux nouveaux réalisateurs,
yokomen esketh, qui sont des cinéastes nominés à l'académie
, revigorent la franchise
avec quelque chose que nous n'avions jamais vu auparavant,
nos nouveaux personnages vont apporter une
nouvelle saveur et un  dimension différente de l'
une des franchises les plus puissantes de
tous les temps lorsque nous avons entendu qu'ils
prévoyaient de créer un autre pirate, nous l'avons
enregistré, nous voulions que cela ressemble à une
balade, soyez Salman effrayant et émotionnel et
cela signifie d'énormes pièces d'action
[Musique]
nous avons puissant  des extras énormes et des
photos épiques avec un emplacement fantastique
ce monde est excitant il se passe quelque chose d'
énorme tous les jours donc il y a une
énergie et bien sûr derrière mais je n'ai
jamais vraiment expérimenté auparavant
non seulement que vous pouvez cuisiner mais nous avons
affaire à des icônes  personnages et comme
seulement changer un élément, j'ai senti qu'il y avait
un sentiment de magie en marchant sur cette
scène, le savoir-faire dans les détails,
il est très facile de se perdre  toi-même et
te sentir comme dans un autre monde
les hommes ne te racontent pas d'histoires